would you consider giving your father a
call
would we consider at least a call was he
apologizing I mean did he ask I mean if
he were to call then I guess we would
see I could get him to text a request
for a call I'm afraid we're gonna need
to hear that voice
let's go
we'll always be good right if we're good
we're good okay
well that's heartening
that's that's heartening I'm heartened
by that
we wanted to do something together
it's not about getting back dad
but if it hurts him it doesn't bother me
I mean it's a tight rope walk on a
straight razor 500 foot reputational
drop
why is that making you smile that should
make you smile he looks tightrope
walking a straight razor
cannot win your dad will wash you away
this is a chess board are you tanking
the deal and every move is crucial like
Israel Palestine correct but harder and
much more important